Let's [laughter]
go. Let's go. Do you think that they're
aware of like how much the insurgent
left like actually hates them? I don't
know if they are. I don't know if like
these Obama Democrats are like tankies.
When John Favreau is really mad that
billionaires aren't donating to the
party, I think he's kind of like a
tankie when it when you think about it.
That's like really tankie-coded.
>> [music]
>> I do want to start here cuz we're going
to talk through the DNC autopsy, some of
the motivations for doing the DNC
autopsy. All right, we're going to look
through all of it. Let's get into it.
You're making it easier for this group
of people that you've rightly identified
to make hay and to like throw rocks at
Democratic Party in an unjustified or I
guess in this context justified manner,
but for the wrong reason. Um I'll give
Hutch a chance if he wants to weigh in.
If not, I can respond. It was the most
predictable Streisand effect ever, and
I'm glad that the people that are in the
leadership position within the party
itself are not super online, but they
need to hire people that are. Like they
need to hire a team of like three or
four zoomers that are super online
because I could have predicted that this
was going to turn into a like they're
going to make it about Gaza. It was like
really really really predictable. And um
And so I don't know if this means that
he should resign at church.
Who made it about Gaza? Like I see that
some people online made it about Gaza,
but who out of the actors that actually
talked to Ken Martin or actually dealt
with Ken Martin were making it about
Gaza?
I understand that there were people on
Twitter who might have done that, okay?
Not that I've seen them. I assume Hutch
has seen them cuz that's what he's
totally obsessed with. That's what he
can't stop talking about. But
but but but but but but but but
Who Who that matters is talking about
Gaza at all? Who cares?
>> seems like that's being teed up, um
which is a little depressing cuz I feel
like people would just
kind of more sinister agendas are behind
that because it seems like the
Democratic Party currently is doing a
really good job of winning elections.
And so, you know, I don't know enough
about his um performance as DNC chair. I
don't really know.
>> Oh, Emma Vigeland? Okay, I I I don't
watch The Majority Report because I
don't
I don't like Emma Vigeland's like takes
on things, basically. So, I'm not sure.
>> Logistically, like if he's doing a good
job, but you know, I'm hesitant to call
for resignations every single time that
particular mob gets pissed. But, also to
Pisco's point, yeah, I mean, this was
like, I think a big and it was kind of
predictable. Um, I think they need
people that are more plugged in into the
online space. There does seem to be a
disconnect and we need some people that
can translate internet for the
>> So, Hutch is talking about the fact that
the fact of not actually releasing the
DNC the autopsy, but also I'm assuming
at some point they're going to talk
about the fact that it was done totally
incompetently.
>> Do you think the people at the top, the
the people in the leadership, do you
think that they're aware of like how
much
the insurgent left like actually hates
them?
>> I don't know if they are. I I think they
do. They just uh, probably discount it
heavily. Like, well, there's people
making noise and those people, I believe
80 to 90% of them end up voting for
Democrats in the end, so they don't
really see a need to try to win them
over.
>> Well, like the McMurrow interview, um,
for example.
>> Mhm.
>> Did you guys all watch that interview
with, um, Matt and Emma?
>> No.
>> It was not as like
>> You know, you know his name now, right?
How do you not just call him the gay
guy?
>> Matt [laughter] Bernstein I think his
name is. Matt Bernstein and Emma
Vigeland. Um, the tone wasn't super
aggressive, but the subtext was. Like,
they were definitely kind of dripping
with contempt. And I just like in that
kind of spot, I wonder if McMurrow
understood that she was walking into an
interview with, you know, two people who
probably like think that she supports
genocide and whatever else thing they're
going with. Um, same same with Slotkin.
I'm not sure if she was aware
of the venue that she was walking into.
>> Why would you be unaware? Why is that
Why is that not on the candidate
themselves to be like aware of the
positions the people they're
interviewing with have and then to pick
their interviews? If they think they're
going to get like a really unfavorable
interview, you wouldn't just go into
like
like you wouldn't just go into any
interview with having no idea of who
you're talking to. That you you hire
like a comms director for this entire
purpose.
>> Breaking Points and, you know, it's not
to say they should never do these kinds
of interviews, but uh, maybe we're
stretching the point, but what I think
there's something there, but I I want to
reject the framing that this is about
the insurgent left or the populist left
versus the insider left or the more
normal left because the people who are
frustrated with Ken Martin the most are
>> Hahaha. [laughter]
>> Oh no, Pisco. Pisco, don't take my
position precisely. I Pisco, you can't
do it. Pisco, don't do it. Pisco, no.
Pisco, no. No. No. Pisco, no.
>> fabulous left versus the insider left or
the more normal left because the people
who are frustrated with Ken Martin the
most are people who are like state
chairs and are people who are inside the
DNC and are people who I don't think can
be classified as like hater of of Dems.
These are the Politico people. These are
um you know, New York Times type people.
So, I I don't really think that the
criticisms of Ken Martin can all be
dealt with
>> Uh these people are the DNC isn't
failing because they don't have the
right middle management. They're failing
because they don't have any charisma.
Geez, I agree on the charisma part. It's
their top-level management is taking a
different strategy and people are very,
very, very concerned about how it's
going to go. Combine that with the lack
of of hm what would the word be?
Diligence on the autopsy and not
releasing it and not admitting what
happened with it. When you put these
things together, the donors are very
worried that all of their money will be
mismanaged. So, instead of donating to
the DNC, they're donating to a lot of
campaigns specifically.
So, the DNC's actually spending all of
its money very early on just supporting
state parties and like like state DNC
parties, right? Like at the
Uh I mean that's that should be obvious
what I mean, right? Instead of what they
usually do is they'll usually raise
money and then they'll put that money
towards ads in specific districts that
are competitive.
Now, they're just giving out the money
to the state DNC parties even in blue
states, right? Just to help them build
up some kind of machine. That's where
that's what this guy wants to do and so
people are very, very concerned that
one, they're not raising very much money
cuz the donors are scared and two, this
guy's spending all of their money so
they have no war chest going into the
midterms. The DNC is like basically at
net neutral. They're they're basically
at like zero dollars. They're not really
going to be able to spend in specific
areas where they think they can push for
a a win.
Now, I don't think the overall Democrat
machine is fundraising that much less,
right? It's just that the DNC is not
raising anything. The overall Democratic
Party, when you take into account the
candidates, the DCCC, the There's one
other one. When you take all this into
account together, I think they're
raising close to the same amount of
money they usually do,
but it's all going to different places.
So, it will depend on is the DNC fine
dropping back and letting people run
their own campaigns and spending on
their own? Like that really relies on
the donors to spend in the right places,
whereas opposed to recent or sorry, in
the recent past, what's happened is they
give the money to the DNC and the DNC
will spend it as appropriate, like as as
the Democratic Party sees it fit, right?
Now the donors are basically deciding
where the money goes instead of giving
it to a a middleman, which is the DNC.
But there's the the DCCC as well.
There's a couple other ones that do this
as well. So, like realistically, Ken
Martin's strategy might actually be
okay,
like the way he's doing it. Yes, DSCC,
yes, and the DCCC, yes, yes, yes. So,
Ken Martin's strategy might actually be
okay.
It's
it's just like the DNC would be taking
on a different role, a less like
hands-on the wheel role,
which might be good cuz they kind of
suck,
to be honest with you. Like that's
that's certainly an argument he could
make. Like we actually suck, so don't
give your money to us or give enough
money to us so we can fund the state
parties and they can like build out
infrastructure, hire people, and get
stuff done, like do door knocking and
stuff, and basically make it so it's
easier to sign up and be a member of the
Democratic Party.
That could be okay. That could be an
okay strategy, right? But it is kind of
going, "Yeah, we suck. Don't give a
bunch of money to us. Don't trust us to
decide where that money should go. Just
donate where you want to donate." That's
I don't know, in a world where
billionaires have like access to insane
statistics and stuff, that might
actually be better
that these people could just run their
own operation and fundraise and and
donate as they see fit. Possible.
Anyway, I I don't know that it actually
matters.
You know what I mean?
I I really don't. I don't know if it
actually matters.
It It might be that the DNC not
fundraising that much is not that big a
deal and Ken Martin is kind of on
course. It's just when you put together
the lack of fundraising with spending a
bunch of their money, having a war
chest, with the failed audit
that the the previous election audit,
right? That Ken Martin's done a couple
things in concert that make people
really squirrely right now. And so a lot
of people are calling for his
resignation all into um awareness about
how bad faith some lefties are.
>> No, that's right. But But the initial
major grievance, I would say, was driven
by the insurgent left with the Gaza
narrative. And I would I would say the
Pod Save guys are aligned with them, but
you
>> That's not true. No, neither of those
things is are true. You're like a total
putz.
Neither of those things are true. Jon
Favreau has been banging on about an
autopsy since the election ended,
basically. I think since December of
2024.
Basically, there's like this war between
the the Obama-aligned people and the
Biden-aligned people. And that's another
sub That's like a sub plot line of this
entire thing is
basically, a lot of the Obama guys think
that the DNC has been run totally
incompetently since they've left, since
they've been out of office, and they
don't want any of the people who are
there and running it to be running it
anymore. Like, they want to step back in
and take it over again. Well, the funny
thing is is they're doing a very the
Obama Democrats, like the more
corporate-aligned Democrats,
Cenk Uygur's demons, OKAY?
>> CORPORATE DEMS!
>> Cenk Uygur's demons, as some might call
them, they are
trying, and I think succeeding,
obviously, from the totally like
knuckle-dragging response,
they're succeeding in co-opting the
leftist movement. They're They're
actually succeeding in this.
Right? They're trying to co-opt that
movement. They're trying to, you know,
Obama goes and does a photo op with
Mondaire Jones.
Jon Favreau pushing, talking to does a
really favorable interview with Hasan
[__]
Right? All this stuff, they're trying to
co-opt that movement and bring it in and
use that energy to get candidates
elected. They're still corporate dems.
They still very much like
are at their heart aligned with and in
service of corporate interests.
But they're trying to bring that other
element in to give themselves like a
veneer of credibility.
Right? And it's so funny that it's
working and the exact people who should
probably be against that, who don't want
the leftists in, are helping them do it.
Right? When you attack Jon Favreau for
his interview on Hasan [__] you're
helping him incorporate Hasan [__] into
the party. You don't even understand
that you're working against the thing
you're trying to stop.
Because you are a low IQ, low impulse
control, zero empathy degenerate. We'll
go back to this.
>> You're right. The state party The state
level Democrats have have [laughter]
been
>> The Obama types?
>> Yeah, yeah, definitely at this point.
I'm not saying they're like tankies or
whatever, but I think that they my
speculation
>> what I was just
I don't know if like these Obama
Democrats are like tankies. When Jon
Favreau is really mad that billionaires
aren't donating to the party, I think
he's kind of like a tankie when it when
you think about it. That's like really
tankie coded. Right? When you're when
you're upset that billionaires won't
give your country party like million
dollar checks, that's like super tankie
coded, I think.
>> of the Democratic Party, Hodge.
>> That's most of the Democrats. People who
think that that that Gaza um is a
genocide or the Israelis committed a
genocide.
>> No, I mean specifically the charge that
they were withholding this report.
>> Because it said that Gaza lost her the
election.
>> I don't think that the Pod Save America
people said that. I heard them come out
after the um Jon Favreau interview and
say that it was because it was shoddy
work This is before it leaked, before it
>> Yes. Yes.
They were saying we think it's been done
poorly. We we don't trust it. It's
incompetence. Who also said Who said
that before they'd even made a
statement? Uh that's me. What What
that's me. That's That was me.
That was me. I said they're they're
pissed cuz they think the Biden staffers
are incompetent. They think anybody
involved with the Biden campaign was
totally incompetent. Anybody who swept
for the Biden campaign so Biden could
run again is totally incompetent and
needs to be needs to metaphorically in a
political sense have their head cut
off." That's what Jon Favreau thinks,
right? And that's what he's been doing.
That's how he's been operating since the
last election. But, it unfortunately
Hutch just can't understand this. Hutch
because well, it's bad. That's why Hutch
can't understand it, okay? Hutch hates
Hasan. Jon Favreau was nice to Hasan.
Anyone who's nice to Hasan is a tankie,
apparently.
>> Oh, yeah, yeah.
>> They had sources. They had sources.
>> So, I don't think they're promoting that
narrative in have anything, right? Like,
this would have died down mostly if Ken
Martin had just never done that
interview. I think that that's probably
what had happened.
>> I I agree and I think he screwed that up
royally, but I I just the the arguments
for why he needs to go and and is
failing are so weird to me. It's like,
well, the DNC doesn't have money, but
we're spending it and we're winning
handily. So, it's like they're
>> Unfortunately, I'm probably going to
agree well, hold on that last part. I
don't think you winning has anything to
do with the DNC spending the money right
now. They're spending the money to build
out the local parties, the the local
party offices, and stuff like this.
That's what they're spending the money
for, right?
Realistically, they're spreading the
money around in a way that
like it could be good in some way,
but there it's not leading to them
winning. They're doing that as a part of
a deeper strategy, a long-term strategy,
which I like. I actually like that.
But,
you cannot think that the spending of
the money in the local parties is what's
doing it. Dude, they're spending money
in every state. That's not helping win
special elections, idiot. How in the
world could you say that throwing $500
or $5,000 to every state party every
month, I think it's 5,000, to every
state party every month, how in the
world could you possibly argue that
that's helping you win special
elections? Spraying the money evenly
instead of spending on those special
elections. That's not what the money is
doing. B
B so for real right now, man. Come on.
They're concerned about an election two
elections from now and
>> to use the bathroom real quick.
>> That you can't think like that. Like if
the guy's doing well right now, you got
to work within the moment. I think it's
a crisis of credibility.
>> Oh, sorry. What's the metric, right? Is
he still funding well fundraising well?
I don't remember. I know right after the
election, obviously fundraising was not
where it needs to be, but people were
waiting for the DNC to come out with a
here's how we're going to win message.
They're waiting to see how these
elections go, how the midterms go. And
once those go and they're like, oh, the
DNC is spending the money well, that's
when the money starts to roll in. But
like these kind of swings just like the,
you know, approval for the party that
lost, like they're they they normally
happen. So, is there like a data that
says they're raising on par with 2020?
Um that I'm not sure off the top of my
head.
>> Well, I think his explanation was that
the donors are donat- donating directly
to the candidates. Um I don't know if
that was just cope, but like for example
in 2016, if you're looking for
historical precedent, the DNC was
literally bankrupt. They were I think
over $10 million in debt and Hillary
bailed them out with her war chest. So,
I don't really know what like the normal
kind of baseline for have funds in the
tank is for this moment in time.
>> Um that's
Does Hutch not realize that the DNC
being bankrupt after a extremely
consequential presidential election
makes total sense? Like that's not a
problem.
That's not the same problem you're
dealing with now. That's after the
election. If they've overspent, if they
borrowed to to sell out to try to win
the election, that makes some sense.
What doesn't make any sense is going
into a midterm before you've even hit
the part the midterm season where you
would be spending on ads, you're
bankrupt. You you got nothing.
Right? That's what's actually
concerning. That's really concerning.
He just made a totally like
that point doesn't even remotely come
close to talking about the problems the
DNC might have.
That's like a fundamentally uninformed
and stupid opinion.
Well, actually after a presidential
election, the DNC was bankrupt. Okay,
before a consequential midterm, the DNC
is functionally bankrupt. That's really
bad. Hutch, that's really bad. Although,
actually I haven't checked their fund or
anything in like a 2 months or
something. They might be back in doing
okay. I'm not totally sure.
But, in any case, from Hutch, that point
he just made doesn't even remotely
answer the question of whether Ken
Martin's doing a good job.
He just talked about some stuff. He just
said some that actually doesn't tie
into the issue at hand in any meaningful
way.
>> Time.
>> Well, I think if you
Well, just real quickly, if you go
toe-to-toe the RNC DNC or the DCCC
versus the Republicans' version, the
Republicans are out-raising us
tremendously with these organizations.
But, when you look at the individual
candidates like James Talarico versus
Ken Paxton or John Cornyn, it's night
and day. We're completely annihilating
them.
>> I just want to say though,
with with the fact of the DNC, I almost
think, you know, whether or not anyone
has any specific expertise on the
fundraising numbers and the individual
races versus the other committees, etc.,
there's a crisis of confidence that I
think needs to be assessed. And that is
the DNC's most important job is
preparing for the presidential election,
the debates, that setting up the rules,
the schedule, that kind of stuff. And
that is where things get very hairy and
where I think they need to have the most
credibility. You see the kind of
problems you saw might say scandal
that's happened in the past where it has
caused us issues. Now that we're facing
a decade past, how many people point to
the Donna Brazil emails of 2016, etc.
>> I mean, I really think this autopsy is
enough of an issue on its own.
Like, the fact that you've been selling
this autopsy, "Hey, we're going to do a
big autopsy. We're going to release it."
And then it turns out to be some
AI-generated total
trash bucket.
Like, that that does not inspire
confidence at all.
>> is an area where I think you need to
overcompensate in terms of being
upfront and being transparent, and
that's crucially what this episode, um,
you know, shows a lack of.
>> Well,
winning has a way of smoothing over all
the problems. So, I think if we have a
stellar midterms, you're going to see a
lot less complaints about Ken Martin.
So, I think he deserves a chance to get
us through the midterms. And if we do
have a bad midterms or not as good of a
midterms, and people can point to some
problems, we can. Then, we've got a
2-year runway to the elections, and I
think it's time to talk about perhaps
stepping down. But right now, that was a
big point in my video is we're less than
6 months from the midterms. This would
be crazy to swap out our coach right
now.
>> Isn't this kind of playing into the
narrative we were talking about last
week and a lot of weeks, which is you're
comparing individual candidates who
might stand on certain policies that
invigorate voters, and you're comparing
this to the DNC, which is supposed to be
this generic apparatus that then
transfers those funds into a lot of
those
elections, and you know, raises money
for this local one and this local one.
If he's unable to do that, like I think
that's what you're measuring him on. If
we do well in the midterms, that could
be completely absent of DNC fundraising.
I'm not saying it it is, but that has no
indication as whether or not he did a
good job. That just means those
candidates, who according to him are the
ones getting the money and not the DNC,
are doing a good job with their
messaging and their campaigns. So, I
think you have to be able to look at
what did you actually do with the money,
and did that actually pan out, or did
you not really have a big effect, right?
>> I I I agree. Another thing that
>> I would ask IRI why he thinks the D- the
DNC has done a good job in any way. Like
what about the DNC and how it's run
has led to wins in these elections?
>> that I didn't include in my video that
people aren't talking about is Trump is
fundraising off of bribes. I mean, he is
asking for money for his ballroom and
all sorts of thing. Like it's a piggy
bank for graft. So, to compare the DNC
to that is a little
uh unfair, I think, too.
>> Was Was somebody comparing the DNC to
that?
>> I agree with that. Like obviously a lot
of the deck is stacked against Democrats
versus Republicans. But I think that
there needs to be some failure state
that we recognize. What it would it take
for us to be like, "Okay, Ken Martin
needs to go." What are the metrics? And
it's the similar kind of question. I'm
not going to demand you guys answer it
now, uh that I often demand of pods.
Like what would it take for you to say
that Schumer's doing a bad job? Now,
Hutch is already
>> Linked to another short 13-ish minute
discussion on the autopsy and who might
replace Ken Martin in the content links.
Probably not as good as content as this,
but maybe a good watch in people's own
time. Okay. All right. We'll check it
out.
>> I'm not trying to mischaracterize him or
anything, but like this is what I'm
talking about that sometimes Democratic
success is in spite of either
incompetence or just kind of genericness
or not particularly superbness on behalf
of some of these institutional figures.
That we're winning in spite of them as
opposed to because of them.
>> So is your is your position that you do
want him to to resign?
>> I'm leaning towards he should go and
just let's let's get someone new and
fresh. I don't I haven't called for it
because to be honest, I'm not like super
read in on the the numbers aspect in the
fundraising. I think anyone who's
calling for the NC chair to step down
should be aware of the relationship to
donors. Um but I am leaning in that
direction because of how horrible this
event has shown him to be from a
character perspective, from a confidence
perspective, from a personnel
perspective. This episode has shown bad
judgment. And so that's why I'm leaning
in that direction.
>> It just feels like
I I understand like you need confidence
in the leadership and sometimes it's not
even really about the performance.
Sometimes the perception is the only
thing that matters. Um
I I guess this feels like such
like a a footnote in terms of what his
day-to-day probably looks like for the
DNC.
>> Truth is I don't really know what his
daily operational sort of
like jobs are and and but this feels
like it would just be on the low end of
important.
>> But isn't that defeated by the idea that
Jon Favreau is like a DNC insider and
he's saying that
he's saying that donors are scared to
donate because they think this this
party is totally incompetent.
That's what's going on here, Hodge.
Donors are scared to donate because they
think the party's totally incompetent.
So it has to be a massive part of his
day-to-day. He has to be trying to fix
these relationships. What the [__] do
you mean? This can't be a big deal to
him. This can't be a part of his
day-to-day. What?
>> Orton, it does sound like he made a bad
decision, but
>> Yeah, and then you say you don't know
how his day-to-day goes, but you're
willing to undercut what Jon Favreau is
saying, what he's telling you.
I believe this being echoed by a lot of
people, too. Matt Yglesias wrote a whole
piece on how much Ken Martin is
up fundraising.
>> It it wouldn't be enough for me to say
that he should step aside. Now like if
if you show me data that shows like, you
know, a lot of the state level Democrats
are just don't have confidence in him,
then I would support calling for him to
step aside, but I just don't know what
>> What did you guys think about the whole
like outing David Hogg thing that
happened way at the beginning of last
year?
>> What happened?
>> Ken Martin and and that kind of ill like
they pushed out David Hogg
uh from
the DNC.
>> I I thought he was pushed out because of
there was some kind of a process issue.
I I don't know.
>> that was that was it was there was some
oh, you need to hire a woman
>> I don't know about this.
>> I never heard of this. Like, "Well, you
weren't a woman, but really it was
because David Hogg was challenging more
center like left Democrats with like,
"Hey, we need to replace these people
who are people who are actually going to
get the job done." Very like you maybe
you want to call it insurgent left kind
of like tactics to say like let's get
more progressive lefties in here. But
>> That's that's pretty
>> The process thing was just an excuse.
>> Well, that's a pretty pretty serious
conflict. Like if you're going to join
the DNC, then you should you should be
on the team. And I'm not saying, you
know, this is a democracy, so you can
branch off and and do your own group and
try to support primary challengers. My
understanding is that he hasn't really
been that successful so far, but I don't
think you can do both of those jobs at
the same time. I do think it's
reasonable to ask that you just do one
or the other.
>> Yeah, I I it was some procedural thing.
They claimed the vote didn't go the way
it was supposed to and there was like
supposed to be another woman. It was a
very soy cringe thing that happened. Um
I disagree with you so
>> Hogg got ousted of the DNC for wanting
to primary centrists. Oh, interesting.
I didn't know that.
That's kind of funny.
Mhm, that changes my estimation of Ken
Martin a little bit.
>> Wait, people did
>> Interesting.
>> to push him out. To this day, I don't
understand why they couldn't work it out
with him, but I disagree with you that
he was pushed out. I don't know, maybe
I'm crazy.
>> It didn't work out because he formed a
group who were [clears throat] doing
primary challenges and it's been DNC
policy for years now to support
incumbents. And so,
that is a pretty intense conflict to
have, you know? I don't know. You know,
>> Should it be DNC policy to support
incumbents? I mean I mean maybe that's
one of the this is maybe different than
the DNC leadership under Ken Martin.
>> So, this is going to be a very
interesting conversation because it's
about supporting the status quo. If
everybody's annoyed with the status quo,
if everybody's frustrated with the
status quo, you're thinking about how
you can inject some populism, economic
populism into your movement so you can
energize voters, right? People are upset
with the status quo. Even if that's a
stupid belief to be upset with the
status quo, even if that's
foundationally stupid.
Do you think you should be publicly
supporting anybody who is pushing away
from the status quo? Oh, sorry,
publishing or publicly
resisting anybody who's pushing away
from the status quo. Like, even if it's
a stupid position, I don't know if you
should publicly resist anybody saying
these things. It doesn't necessarily
make sense to me. It sort of makes you
look like the the party of status quo,
the party of um
institutional dominance. Like, as much
as I do believe in institutions, I think
there's some concerning level of There's
There's something concerning there that
everybody's saying everything is right
now and you're going, "Whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. We need the
exact same thing right now. We need the
exact same thing."
That That to me, it feels like there's a
mismatch between what the voter where
the voters are at and where the party is
at.
>> And then now just talking more generally
about what the Democrats' position
should be, but I think a lot of
incumbents need to go. I think a lot of
Democrats One of the reasons, even
though I I know that IRI discounts a lot
of polling and stuff, but one of the
reasons I think the Democrats are
souring on their own party is because of
some of these old like old guard figures
that have no reason that they don't, you
know, believe in.
>> Wasn't the Wasn't the big problem with
2016 that people felt like the DNC was
showing a bias? Like, I I [laughter]
don't know if like that
>> Well, well, I'm just asking I thought
you said that it's the DNC policy to
support incumbents. And that's a bias in
favor of incumbents.
>> Right, but but it seems like you're
you're proposing a a new system where
they would, you know, potentially
support primary challenges, which means
>> Well, I'm just I'm just questioning
whether or not if it is a policy to
support incumbents as a matter of
course, what's what's the wisdom of that
policy?
>> Well, I think strategically it makes
sense cuz incumbents have such an
advantage. Um but but again, I I
you this would be introducing a new kind
of a new kind of bias into the DNC,
which basically runs counter to the the
criticism from 2016. So, I I don't know.
I like is it the right decision? I don't
>> It might be statistically right. I know
it caused Nancy Pelosi to support that
like, you know, pro-life Democrat in
Texas for that one house seat, which was
I think it was just an atrocious
decision. So, I I don't think there
should just be this hardline support the
incumbent. It should be support like the
candidate who wins the primary, right?
Um like if you're like putting your
>> By the way,
if they do have a national policy to
support the incumbent,
then
what Oh, man.
Then isn't a lot of the rhetoric towards
the lefties by Hutch like wrong? Like,
"Oh, just, you know, guys, just win the
primaries." It's like, "Well, no,
there's an institutional bias. They
literally are institutionally set up to
support the candidates." There's a bias
there you're not referencing or not like
winking at or or acknowledging when you
say, "Oh, well, just support the
candidate."
Right? Like, "Oh, but the party is going
to support the incumbent, who's
obviously in most cases not going to be
a progressive."
>> toe on the scale of those primaries.
Like, shouldn't the Democratic voters
get to decide which Democrat's the best
one? And once that's the case, your job
is to beat Republicans, not to pick like
which Democrat is the one that you like
more? I don't know. I don't like that
idea, and I don't like the idea of
funding from the Democratic Party going
to like kind of affecting primaries in
that way, but I I'd have to look and see
like what the actual outcomes are in the
majority. That was the one time where I
really focused on that other than the
Bernie-Hillary stuff, so.
>> I And if I was going to support him Oh,
go on.
>> A competition is good. I I don't think
the Democratic Party should stand in the
way of people being challenged. You
should have to fight for your job every
time. It just makes you stronger.
>> 100% I agree.
>> last
Well, one last thing I just wanted to
add is like when I met Ken Martin uh in
San Francisco, and he was doing this
thing that was supposedly my
understanding was I'm out I'm reaching
out to creators because we just lost the
election, and we want to figure out how
we can do what Hutchin and I and all of
you guys are talking about, which is,
"Hey, we need some cool like young
voices to like get their finger on the
pulse of where the country is cuz our
media strategy doesn't work." And he was
talking about like, "We fired all the
media strategists in 2024." But he did
not, I don't think, ask a single
question of any of the people there
about how to
>> [laughter]
>> He was just preaching? Well,
I need to talk to all of the influencers
who have their finger on the pulse. Now,
listen to me tell you what you should be
telling people.
>> It was all him reassuring us. Like, by
the way, and this is what we're doing
right. As if to like make us his
cheerleaders. And I'm like, well, this
is not what you should be doing.
Contrasted to Gavin Newsom met with some
people at TwitchCon, and he was asking
really good questions. Like, what kind
of audiences do you have? How do these
messages disseminate? What do What are
they looking for? What are people in
your audience like What are the problems
that they're most focused on? Can did
none of that. And that did not inspire
me with confidence. So, as to whether or
not he should step down, I've seen time
and time again, maybe he's fundraising
well, but he's just making poor
decisions that I don't think are going
to be putting the money in the right
spot. And I would rather someone who,
you know, inspires me with confidence.
But, if the people that he is giving the
money to are inspired by this, and
they're like, "Hey, you're doing a good
job. You're helping my race out." then
that's really the most important metric.
And you know, I'm just an influencer, so
I can't speak to whether or not he
should step down. It's just what I'm
getting.
I want to say one one other thing, which
is um
Well, if you take the view,
I
don't necessarily think it's just the
people who he's funding. I think there
would be something with the donors. You
do need donors who are confident in the
Democratic Party, who are willing to
donate money. You need to. You You need
that, okay? That's the way this works,
right? That is You have to be willing to
court money. I understand that it would
be nice to get money out of politics, at
least to some some far more significant
degree than has been done so far.
But, in the current environment, you do
have to court these people, and his
inability to do that, his inability to
do that, is a problem.
And I do believe that actually the
problem is mostly with him, based on the
Matt Yglesias article we read on stream
before. It is like him having personal
issues with donors. It's them not liking
him as a personality, as a person.
That is not good for a DNC chair, whose
primary job is really about raising
money.
>> That Jon Favreau did something like
horrible in that exchange with Ken
Martin. Um I just think that and if Or
if Ken Martin thought it was a good idea
to go in there antagonistically, as he
did in my view he did. Um not to say
that Jon Favreau wasn't like obviously
going down a strict line of questioning
there. I I I just don't think that
you're in tune in with the Democratic
base. My view of it which is most people
want to see more fight. Most people want
to see a closer connection to the the
voting members. And I just don't have
the confidence um that he is doing that
right now and that he has the um you
know, self-reflection perhaps to to make
those changes unless it's in his direct
interest or when it gets like out of
hand. And we're we need to be like
ruthless. And part of being ruthless
means if it is appropriate at the time
to make a change in leadership. And like
let's not just rest on our laurels. Uh
we learned that lesson or I thought we
learned that lesson from Biden. Um so,
you know, that's just something I want
to carry forward in all walks of
Democratic leadership.
>> Well, I I I just I feel like
Pod Save America and it it sounds like
whatever show McMorrow went on, like
they're they're not trying to help it in
my opinion. It it may seem like it and
if you ask them they'll tell you, "I'm
just trying to help." But the way they
frame their questions and the the way
they interrogate these people just makes
you
>> Dude, IRI was like completely moronic
when he reviewed this stuff. When he
talked about the Ken Martin interview,
like Ken Martin directly lied to Jon
Favreau. That is That is literally Jon
Favreau
pressing Ken Martin for lying to him
directly.
It's not It's not about the Dems at that
point. It is the DNC chair went on
the the Pod Save podcast and said,
"We're releasing this and oh, there's a
bunch of other stuff, too. Oh."
He He kept talking about how like we
have lessons and all of this as well,
right? Oh guys, we've learned a bunch of
lessons here. Oh, we might need to watch
a little bit of that Jon Favreau. I've
watched it personally, but I have not
watched it on stream yet.
The the actual like follow-up interview.
We watched a decent amount of it with
IRI as well.
Oh no, I've watched a decent amount of
it through IRI.
Okay, but like
IRI was getting really mad at them for
bagging on Ken Martin. It's like, "Dude,
Ken Martin directly lied. What lessons
are you pushing out? What lessons did
you learn from the report that you're
pushing out when you then publish the
report and show actually this was done
incompetently and you say you don't
about any of the results.
That's nuts.
Like you just lied directly to his face.
Of course he could be pissed about it.
>> that they're not even trying to figure
anything out because they can't point to
anything positive. It's all negative and
they they seem just completely convinced
that something needs to change as we win
by double digits in and I just I don't
get that vibe Pisco that these guys are
actually trying to help.
Well, I don't think they're on the right
or mega or fake you know Democrats but
why are they so angry? Why are they so
convinced they're right and there's no
love or anything no support in any way.
I'm not
first thing I'll take on is like this
notion of their antagonism. Aren't they
vindicated by Ken Martin's response? I
mean Ken Martin came out and said I'm
sorry it was the wrong move uh with
respect to the report. Doesn't that mean
that Jon Favreau even Ken Martin
acknowledges was correct in the
criticism of the reports?
>> He was but but we could have convinced
Ken Martin to release the report in a
much different way. You know what I
mean? Like if Ken Martin came on this
show we could raise the same concerns in
the way they did in a completely
different way because we're doing it
from a place of hey we want to And I
don't get that vibe from them. I just
get they just want to antagonize. Yes,
but Ken Martin went with the approach
that Pod Save to do the interview on
that issue and so it's not
>> Ken Martin went explicit Oh, Pisco.
Pisco definitely watched my video on
this. Pisco watched me like
Oh, I know he did. I hate to you know
suck myself off but Pisco absolutely
watched the exact points I made about
how
obviously Ken Martin went into this
interview knowing that it was going to
be hostile. He explicitly wanted to
argue with somebody about whether or not
the report should be released and then
he lied to try to make his point.
Obviously, come on man.
>> It cannot be I think reasonably
construed as an ambush. If uh Martin is
seeking out an interview with Pod Save
America on this issue and he knows it's
going to come up. He knows it's about to
critique. In fact, he goes up to Favreau
specifically because he's mad at the
critique. Then in no sense can I say
that this is an attempt by Pod Save to
try to like with Ken Martin.
>> Obviously.
>> If you watch that interview, the counter
arguments that Ken Martin was giving
were not really addressing what Jon
Favreau was saying. Jon Favreau had a
criticism and Ken Martin had this kind
of like rehearsed like, "Well, actually
there's no smoking gun." to a question
that didn't really suggest that there
was because he was so used and knew
these criticisms were going to come up
that he was already kind of getting
ahead of things that John wasn't even
asking yet. So, it's not as if he like
walked in blind and got ambushed. He was
very aware that this was like I want to
fix the off
>> Wait, there's no way Slotkin asked for
the turning point or the breaking points
interview.
There's no way that Slotkin asked for
that breaking points interview and then
went on and was shocked that Cristobal
was mad about Gaza.
That's not possible.
There's no way.
There's no way they're they're framing
this as an ambush the whole time.
And it's just very clear that
like what was going to happen. It's It's
obvious to anybody.
The comms person didn't debrief her um
but
>> this.
>> Oh, boy.
>> much of it I think he was like answering
questions that weren't being asked
because he was so ready for this to be
like a Gaza, Gaza, Gaza sort of thing,
right? So, I I I'm not sure this is like
a oh, we're being so unfair. If you look
at the McMorrow interview, the questions
they ask are, "Hey, like we like, you
know, XYZ policy, but in general like
this healthcare thing you just said, we
fundamentally disagree with. You are
implying that she watches this back and
says it's a joke, but she implied that
if you have government in charge of
healthcare and then Donald Trump gets in
office, it will be bad. Therefore, the
government shouldn't be in charge of
that social program." which is an absurd
thing to say. That's not how anyone
views social programs. Like, "Oh, we
couldn't have them because if a
Republican gets in office, they'll be
run poorly." Um so, they confronted her
on that cuz it's like, "Hey, this is a
fundamental disagreement from what would
have otherwise appeared to be two
aligned Democrats." And I don't think
this is just like I just want to be
antagonistic. It's like, "Hey, this this
is disqualifying for someone that I
would vote for in a primary over the
person that's not going to say cut
social programs."
>> But But there you go, Slotkin, you
nailed it. They're always looking for
disqualifying thing. It's like the
answer
That would piss me off so much. I go in
I construct this like argument this
well-thought-out argument to make
deliver my point and then somebody just
totally thought terminates on the word
disqualify and just goes, "They're
always talking about disqualifying
somebody. It's all about purity testing.
Don't you guys see that this is always
about a purity test and really not about
Bro, could you answer the ques I just I
just worked so hard. I had to go look
stuff up. I had to read articles. I had
to talk to people. I bounced this
argument off a couple people. And then
you just thought terminated on one word
and don't respond materially to anything
I say.
Do you understand how frustrating that
is?
That's incredibly frustrating when
somebody does that to you, right?
I know I do that to people sometimes.
I'm sure it happens all the time. But
when you're the person who's like laying
out a very meticulous argument and
someone does that to you, it
sucks.
>> for these guys is just to fire and get
rid of things. They they never want to
work with what's right in front of them
in any way. It's always like this you
got to go or you got to get fired. It's
like that's not how life works, you
know? It's like we're a family. You you
don't just fire your family. You work
with them.
>> It's just it's a new kind of incarnation
of Bernie or Bust. It's like Saagar or
Bust.
>> Dude, oh do not do not talk about
Saagar, you bald coward.
Keep Abdul El-Sayed's name out your god
damn mouth, Hutch. Holy
I You know what? Have they talked about
the Abdul El-Sayed thing? I hope Hutch
gets pressed on that cuz his
>> conversation it's like you're
interviewing
>> His takes on El-Sayed were shameful.
Totally shameful, man.
You are out of your god damn mind.
Okay. All right. I need to I need to
remain calm. I need to remain calm.
>> viewing a US Senate Senate candidate who
will be a part of so many consequential
votes that address dozens of like
consequential issues in this country
and it's an hour-long interview and you
spend 15 minutes pressing her on
Medicare for All, a policy that
>> Ryan Girdy in the chat. I think Bad and
the Todd Save Guys are different. Pod
Save Gurley Martin is part of Insider
Dem Establishment Beef.
Oh, it's like the people who actually
pay attention to politics seem to all
Dude,
I
I just think it's funny that I I put
these ideas out. I know they're correct.
I know I'm saying the right thing.
I had a whole thing dude, I actually
worked to go and find all the stuff cuz
I knew I knew I had a point here.
Like one of the only political stories
I've really followed from the start
in the past like year or so.
And it's just cool seeing all the people
who actually know anything about
politics, all the people who actually
put any work into politics
all agree with my exact take on it. It's
so nice. It just feels good, right? When
I've been doing a bunch of drama stuff
and you come back to the politics stuff
and everybody who pays any attention
just totally agrees.
You love to see it. You love to see it.
>> to passing in the Congress. It's not
going to pass in the next Congress or
the one after that probably. Probably
not the one after that either. Um and
then the rest of the 45 minutes is on
Gaza. And it's like, okay, that's we can
have a conversation about Gaza and
foreign policy, that's fine. But I just
feel like to IRI's point, they're not
there with any kind of curiosity.
It is for them a
broader campaign, a broader agenda of
like wiping out the Democratic Party of
everyone that is not in their particular
tent. And it's extremely hostile and
antagonistic and you know,
it's a little uncomfortable to be in a
coalition with these people. I don't
think Emma's as bad as other lefties. I
mean, she was pushing for
>> I mean, I'm sure some people who believe
there's a genocide happening in Gaza,
they probably feel a little
uncomfortable being with people who aid
and abet a genocide, right? I would say
the discomfort goes
bi-directionally, right? It probably
goes both ways. Those people are
probably very, very, very uncomfortable
sharing a party with people who are
like, "No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, we should actually send a bunch of
arms to Israel still."
Like, actually, you seem kind of
monstrous. You seem kind of like evil,
possibly.
That That might be a lot of people's
opinion.
It's not shocking that they want to make
an issue out of it. This is like saying,
you know, the the people who
who talk about abortion, who who are
pro-life, it's like being shocked when
they're upset that you are pro-abortion.
Like, no, they they think like maybe not
to the extent of like, you know, another
human being, but they think a life's
being ended, right? Of course they're
upset.
If you can't even enter the conversation
with some understanding of their like
moral framework, then you'll never reach
any understanding with them whatsoever.
The idea that you just can't fathom them
being upset about this thing,
that's bizarre to me.
>> For people to vote for Kamala, you know,
like
I don't I wouldn't put her on the same
tier as like Hasan or anything like
that, but Yeah, but she's a well-known
division because of the Democratic
Party.
Yeah, but come on, he's got 45 minutes
on Gaza. 45 minutes?
>> Oh, I mean, I don't know I haven't seen
the interview. 45 minutes on Gaza seems
like way too much for an interview with
a Senate candidate. Um, so I mean, yeah,
if if it's 45 minutes there, I'm going
to be honest, I haven't seen it. I'm
just responding to what you're saying.
But on the on the point about Medicare
for All versus uh public option versus
increasing Affordable Care Act and all
that stuff, these are not like some out
there divisions in the Democratic Party.
This was the basis of the 2020 campaign,
Sanders against uh Joe Biden. It's one
of the biggest, you know, I I I guess
policy ideological disagreements between
those two. And I think if if you're you
can't be surprised by that. If you're a
Democratic candidate running a
Democratic primary, and this is one of
the big divisions in the Democratic sort
of ideological camp, you got to be ready
for that and just knock it out of the
park. And yeah,
>> I think he did fine for the record. He
should
>> I think she did fine. I don't think
that's a problem. 45 minutes on Gaza, I
mean, that seems like too much, but it
just to be aware, like, this is also now
a crystallizing moment for the
Democratic Party, where we are Israel
skeptic. We don't want and I'm just
speaking now for the majority of the
Democratic Party, we don't want to give
military or economic aid to Israel based
on what their conduct is in the Middle
East, to say nothing of the Iran war.
And that just is a position we want to
see reflected in the Democratic Senate.
I want to see that position reflected in
the in the Democratic Senate. Now, do I
want 45 minutes? No, but uh I do think
it's fair to ask those questions.
>> Well, you said it's she's not Hasan,
right? And I agree. And like, what's the
fundamental difference there? The
difference is I fully support people
rallying and criticizing and getting
attacked from the left in primaries
because you want to push the people that
you are going to be represented by to be
more aligned with you. I think this is
the time to do it. To go, "Hey, there's
two Democrats in this primary.
>> This is literally when they're doing
when they're talking about Planer and
stuff,
like that was that was their argument,
right? Well, Well, primary season.
During the primaries, we're allowed to
do this.
But apparently not on anybody I don't
Dude, I don't know. I've given up on
trying to really make it consistent in
any way.
>> Let's talk to the one who might have a
better chance of winning and see if we
can move the needle a little bit.
>> That's not what they're doing, though.
That's not what they're doing. Come on.
>> I don't What do you mean? If you're
challenging her things that aren't as
left as you and saying like I think you
need to change on that, that's exactly
the time to do it. What's wrong with
that?
>> They're They're side or bust. It's not
like, well, I could warm up to her.
>> No, but you know the side You know
that's like Emma is not side or bust.
She's not
you know, whatever primary person or
bust, Bernie or bust. She's like, "Hey,
go vote for Kamala. Kamala needs to
win." Right? That The majority of our
people are not dead-enders. So, if you
were talking We You and I have the same
smoke for Hasan, which is if you're
going to criticize, criticize,
criticize, and then not even help when
it comes to the general, all you've done
is hurt, right? Because you didn't get
what you wanted, and now you're going to
sabotage our chances. That's what
>> you're subpoenaed.
>> Yeah. Now we'll get to that. We'll get
to that. I mean, here I guess maybe most
more sense to some of these supers like
as they're relevant. They say promoting
better, you know, and this is
opinionated, primary candidates and
demanding better party conduct so Dems
win more if that was the case. Again,
this is making assumptions, is helping
the Democratic Party. I mean, it depends
on who you're promoting and why. But
it's the it's the time [laughter] to do
it, right? It's during the primary.
You're supposed to say, "Hey, I would If
you're going to win
>> Like Hudge goes into these
conversations, and he's foundationally
just thinking if you're like a lefty
candidate, you're the worst candidate
automatically. That's why he does this
thing. By the way, he can't not be this
person, right? He can't not be this like
overconfident, arrogant
>> more if that was the case. Again, this
is making assumptions, is helping the
Democratic Party. I mean, it depends on
who you're promoting and why. But it's
the it's the time
>> Like he he just like scoffs at people
all the time. He's just scoffing,
treating them like they're dumb.
And realistically, I've no problem with
that if that's the dynamic. But then
when other people do this to him, when
other people do this exact same behavior
back to him,
he loses his mind.
He's like a total whiny about it.
Like whatever. If you're If you're going
to let it go with everybody else, that's
fine, okay? You can do your scoffs. And
then when somebody scoffs back at you,
okay.
Don't get Don't get weird about it.
But he totally seems to think that he
should be protected. He should be
treated nicely, and he fails to do that
with his friends so often.
It's so obvious, and I get so irritated
watching it.
>> Well, right? It's during the primary.
You're supposed to say, "Hey, I would If
you're going to win
I don't When's the When When are we
allowed to criticize the
>> Because that person's super chat is
talking about 2028. So, the time to
think about 2028 is after these
midterms, not before. That's what
strikes
>> The time to criticize is is
like not right after the election. We
need to unite cuz we need to fundraise,
and it's not right before the midterms
cuz we need to unite cuz we need to win
the midterms. And then after the
midterms, like maybe there's a little
bit of time to criticize, but then it's
on to 2028. We're You know, by the time
we're 3 months out from the midterms, we
are on to 2028. Why would you be
criticizing going into 2028, guys? It's
They will always find a reason to make
the same argument. So, you kind of just
have to like move it away, right? Just
like ignore it entirely. Oh, this is not
the time.
Well, if it's not the time now, it'll
never be the time.
I Anytime somebody argues this is not
the time, you could all If they've ever
argued that before,
okay? Or if they argue that with any
frequency whatsoever, just throw it out.
If it's like there's times where you can
argue that, right?
Like
I don't know why I went here.
If somebody is like injured, somebody
gets their arm cut off in an industrial
accident, and then you argue with the
medic about like what's for lunch or
what why it's like bad to have certain
cafeteria items on the menu. It's like,
"DUDE, NOW'S NOT THE TIME."
RIGHT? The medic's got to go. But for
this, it's just for the DNC, it's never
the time. For the Democrats, it's never
the time.
When will be the time?
>> Driving me nuts is that all these people
are like concern trolling about 2028,
but we don't even see the midterm
results yet. They're not They're not
trying to push McMorrow left. They're
drawing like the battle lines that have
been drawn, you know? And And as far as
like I'm glad that Emma tells her
audience that, you know, the the harm
reduction principle is is valid, and
they should support Kamala and but for
example like on the off-cycle election
last November, you know, I watched a bit
of their live coverage and you know,
obviously they were elated over Mondaire
as they should have been. That was a
really big win.
Um
but they were actively like downplaying
they were so salty about
Mikie Sherrill and Abigail Spanberger's
Abigail Spanberger's margins. They were
they were legitimately pissed off that
people were talking about how crazy
those margins were and they they thought
that it was like some plot to like under
undermine this, you know, the real
winner of that night which was Mondaire.
So, you know, like they're on the team
but you know, they're not like the best
people to have on the team cuz
when it's not an election year, they're
constantly using their platforms to
accuse people like McMurrow who is, you
know, somewhere on the spectrum between
like center-left and progressive. She's
like decently progressive and if you
didn't get Medicare
>> Hold on. Hold on.
Hold on.
Wait.
If it's not an election year they're
using their platforms. I thought you
said oh listen, they can have
differences of opinion but when it comes
to election time they've got to fall in
line.
Have we just moved the goalposts again?
Has Huch realized that like probably a
bunch of the people I was criticizing
actually did use their platforms to
support Kamala Harris and actually
probably did support the Democratic
candidate and have done so in most
elections and so now he realizes that
criticism was stupid.
And so now he's falling back to a
totally different criticism which is
like well, actually if if off years if
in off years they still criticize then
that's bad too. It's like okay, so your
position is all criticism of the
Democratic Party is immoral.
I know that's not your position but
that's what you're essentially putting
out here.
>> If we had a public option it would still
be awesome and it would drive costs down
and it would expand coverage to so many
people and so to them I just don't like
the all or nothing mentality. I don't
think it's helpful.
>> It's not all or nothing, right? We both
agree that these people specifically are
not all or nothing people. They're hey,
we didn't get what we want and this is
why we've got to support those people
and you can be salty that you didn't get
what you want. Like, you know, I could
be mad Bernie didn't win in 2020 and
still say, "And here's where we're all
going to go out and campaign for Joe
Biden cuz this is such a better option."
That's what I'm going to do
enthusiastically.
>> Have the goal post moved for Hutch
again?
Dude, have they really moved again?
There's no way, right? There's no way
these goal posts have moved another
time.
>> That's what I do. That's not all or
nothing. That's I criticized them when I
had the chance. I wanted this. I didn't
get it. I'm salty about it. And you know
what? I'm still going to help you win.
And if they're in the tent, they're in
the tent, right? And that's those are
That's Emma. Okay, I don't know about
Bernie Sanders. I don't know enough
about him, but like
>> My guy.
>> Well, these are not just
These are not just policy disagreements
though. Um I would like to get back at
like as a party to get back to a place
where we can have policy disagreements
and it doesn't mean that you're, you
know, like if if you don't meet their
purity test, they designate you as like
a pro-Israel, pro-genocide,
pro-corporation shill. And you know,
everybody else is like in their
>> Yep. Okay.
If you don't meet their purity test, on
Israel?
Like
I'm sorry, do they represent people who
are not pro-Israel as pro-Israel?
I I don't like
Uh
>> In their tent.
>> But really we're talking about like 95%
of the party. That's what I don't like.
Like it's it's not about like just
policy disagreements. Does that make
sense?
>> 95% of the party is with who?
>> I'm saying 95% of the party would not
pass their purity test.
>> Oh, of the
>> Like actual actual actual elected
Democrats.
>> Here's the way to test it, Hutch. If
>> Hutch has basically just hit on the true
problem with the Democratic Party.
A massive majority of the Democratic
Party supports like basically not giving
aid to Israel anymore, possibly even
weapons embargoes against Israel, okay?
But Hutch just hit it perfectly that a
lot of the elected representatives
somehow don't give a [__] about what
their constituents think and have
decided to continuously support Israel
anyway.
If they're not going to represent their
voters on this issue at all, what the
[__] are we even doing here? Primary
them.
Obviously, there is no reason this is
actually a fundamental problem that is
going to [__] you over in elections,
[__]
Obviously, it will.
Right? If you have a like a wedge issue
that Okay, let's say let's say foreign
policy is not or even Israel's not high
up on people's list. But if you work
against the entire constituency on that
one issue, like right? Like let's say
people think um
What if women's reproductive rights were
not high on the list? And so the whole
party, despite being the party that is
that all the constituents are
pro-choice, they start going pro-life.
But it doesn't like it it's not high up
in the decision matrix, so it doesn't
like immediately cost them votes.
Why would you just operate against 95%
of your party? Like as a
broadly like it Sorry. Uh why as 95% of
the elected representatives would you go
against 80% of your constituents?
That doesn't make any sense to me. Some
breakaways in terms of red states or
purple states might make sense.
But how does the broad-based the
majority of Democrats how do they
consistently pull away from their
constituency on this one issue?
>> Why do these lefty channels like Pod
Save America or whatever Majority Report
>> This lefty channel This lefty channel
like Pod Save America and Majority Pod
Save America and Majority Dude, somebody
get Emma Vigeland on the line and show
her that clip right there. These Pod
Save America and and the Majority Report
are equivalently or essentially
equivalent. Dude, Emma Vigeland would
lose her
She would lose her
mind, man.
That would be so funny to watch Emma
Vigeland react to that.
>> Ask the Why do these lefty channels like
Pod Save America or whatever Majority
Report
>> [laughter]
[laughter]
>> Ah.
>> [laughter]
>> THAT'S AWESOME. THAT'S AWESOME. We love
that. We love that for Pisco. Okay.
Dude.
God help me. Lord save me. Lord protect
me from
Lord forgive ME FOR WHAT I MUST DO.
>> [laughter]
>> THEY ASSUME THAT THESE people are like
evil almost. That they they
say there's there's like no charity at
all that they're coming from a good
place and that they just have a
different approach to things and and
they're even for people within our own
party. It's it's mind-blowing. I could
talk to the most leftist socialist
person ever and it wouldn't be a
fistfight because I think they're coming
from a good place. I disagree with them
but I I I'm not going to attack them
like they're a monster, you know.
>> Pod Save can't be considered one of
those lefty shows. They're like
in favor of promoting Act Blue and like
and they were all in on Kamala Harris to
win the election.
>> Thank you only well not only same person
seems like Soy Pills
towing the same line today to as well.
So thank you. Pisco, thank you for
saying the thing that is obvious.
>> 100% trying to raise money and and get
us across the finishing line. They're
Obama bros. Are they really like lefty
types uh that they're not quite like
they're not quite like Hasan but I think
that they've definitely positioned
themselves to be
more aligned with like that space for
sure.
>> They positioned themselves to reap
rewards from being kind to those people.
They are not at all what what
concessions have they given?
What concessions have they given to the
to Hasan or that coalition?
Hutch or IRI, please tell me. What
concessions have the Pod Save America
guys given to Hasan?
You know what they did? They did the
intelligent thing, the thing you're
incapable of and they went hey Hasan,
why don't you come on and just hang out
cuz we want to be your friend." And
Hasan can come on and he can go, "I
think it'd be really cool if we did
Medicare for All." And they go, "Like,
that's really cool, man.
What's your workout plan? Oh, that's
cool. Awesome. Awesome. Well, thanks for
coming on and come back another time.
We love you, man. Have a good one.
Right? That's what they do.
That's That's literally all they do.
>> Like when Like when am I
>> It's not that hard.
>> Whenever you want.
>> criticize, it's just how you're doing it
that I have a problem with. Not you
personally, but in general. I have a
problem with how these people, the
Hasans of the world, are criticizing the
Democratic Party. It doesn't feel
genuine. It feels that they have an
agenda as Hutch was saying.
>> Would you agree?
>> Hold on. Wait. Wait. Wait.
>> Yeah.
>> I Maybe I'm going to start strive.
Hutch, when you repost the El Saied is
lying about his doctor credentials, is
this the right way to CRITICIZE
>> [laughter]
>> LET'S GO. LET'S GO.
I love this Abdul El Saied guy, okay? If
you guys aren't If you guys haven't been
here, I love to this guy's background.
This guy is like elite human capital.
This guy has been awesome everywhere
he's ever gone. And the people who have
been denigrating him are this
Call of Duty player and a
uh failed a music school dropout who is
a carpet cleaner. Those are the people
who are judging the Rhodes Scholar who
obtained a PhD and MD in like what? Six
Six years? Seven years?
This guy This guy went crazy. This guy
is elite. This guy is By the way, while
being the captain of the Oxford lacrosse
team.
One of the captains of the Oxford
lacrosse team while he went to Oxford to
study.
Guys,
this This dude is elite human capital.
How dare you criticize this man who has
titanic discipline, who is who is an
absolute titan, okay? How dare you? How
dare you criticize this man and say
maybe he's not Maybe I'm calling himself
a physician is a little too much. It's
not.
It's not.
>> as a candidate when it has nothing to do
with his policy, but it's a character
attack on whether or not he's been
misleading the public.
thing to do with his policy,
but [clears throat] it's a character
on whether or not he's been misleading
the public.
>> I don't even know if I
>> Is your Is your agenda that you don't
like his policies?
>> I don't even I don't even know if I I
don't even know what what Why are you
asking me about that? Why are you asking
me about that?
>> And so you're going on about the doctor
thing or is it like this person's
untrustworthy? Like to me, this would be
far beyond what they did to McMorrow and
it actually might be a legitimate
criticism, right? It's like hold on, if
this guy's lying to people, this is not
a legitimate person we should be
trusting. However, I think that to say
that that's allowed and what you know,
having McMorrow on and asking her
questions about the things she said is
an unacceptable way.
>> If you want to really nail someone
>> I think the way we're posing the story
is worse.
>> No, let's do it. Let's do it one for
one. Let's say you invited El Sayed and
you were grilling him on the doctor
thing. Would you say it's unacceptable?
>> No, I don't think so at all.
At all. At
>> So, why would that be different than the
Israel thing? Why is that any different
than the Israel issue? What?
>> Oh, but there's a difference
>> Did it turn out to be he wasn't
misleading at all and he proved it?
Well, it's that basically people think
if you're not a practicing physician,
you shouldn't say you're a physician.
But I don't believe that's a protected
term in Michigan.
Right? In New York, he might have given
an interview where he called himself a
physician
and it is a protected term and he
shouldn't have done that, but it's like
one infraction in New York. He's not in
New York, he operates in Michigan,
right? And it's like a ticky-tack rule.
He got his MD, he did do rounds as like
a med student and he decided not to go
into medicine like as a field. He was
going to try to be a surgeon. And he
decided not to do a residency, like a
surgical residency. He decided to
actually go into public policy instead,
right? Epidemiology and public policy.
And he did a bunch of research papers,
he taught for a little bit, and then he
went into actual public policy to run as
a politician. He decided that the best
way to use his MD, his knowledge of the
human body, of how you run a met like
any medical operation, he decided to use
these things to inform his healthcare
policy and run as a politician because
he thought that was the scale at which
he could affect the greatest change, the
greatest positive change in the world.
And so he talks about healing the
system, healing America. And he uses
these terms and allegories toward like
allegories from medicine.
And they basically freak the [__] out
and said, "You're not really a doctor or
physician. Why are you doing this?" It's
like, "Well, he's got an MD, and he's
been very transparent about his entire
path through his entire career."
And this is not even the first time this
attack has been attempted.
It's just sad to me that this guy who is
again, like totally like
This guy has worked so hard to get to
where he is as young as he is in his
life. This is a guy you want leading
people. This is a guy you want in a
position of authority. This is a guy you
want making decisions. This is a
fantastic human being who by all
accounts is great at every single thing
he's ever attempted. Why wouldn't you
want this guy in politics? Why are you
trying to chase this guy out of
politics?
You should be going, "Thank you. Thank
you, LORD JESUS, FOR PROVIDING this man
to me who can lead my countrymen, who
can be a great example of American
ingenuity, of American like drive, and
just American greatness overall."
Why the [__] would you ever question
this guy on, "Oh, well, he called
himself a physician."
Dude, it's so insane to me. The Blaze is
crazy? Well, it should be though. It
should be.
Why the [__] Dude, Kash Patel is like a
failed middling prosecutor.
And they put him in government. Why not
put somebody who's elite, who's been
great at everything they've ever done in
government?
Why would you chase this guy out? Why
would you smear this guy?